comme pour la loi de 2021 pour le
renforcement de la prévention en santé
au travail il nous appartiendra de faire
fructifier le résultat d'un dialogue
social très constructif initié par le
gouvernement et plus particulièrement
par vous monsieur le ministre puisque
vous aviez invité les partenaires
sociaux à engager en septembre 2022 une
négociation interprofessionnelle afin de
renforcer le partage de la valeur au
sein des entreprises et améliorer
l'association des salariés aux
performances de l'entreprise cette
négociation peut le dire a été
conclusive et a permis la rédaction d'un
accord national interprofessionnel le 10
février dernier signé par les principaux
syndicats nationaux nous pouvons parler
d'ici d'une véritable réussite du
dialogue social auquel nous devons nous
tenir lors de nos travaux de
transcription dans la loi par respect
pour le travail des partenaires sociaux
nous procédons cet après-midi à la
discussion générale en compagnie donc du
ministre qui va d'abord nous présenter
le texte je passerai ensuite la parole à
notre rapporteur Louis Marguerite et à
la rapporteur pour avis de la commission
des finances je leur souhaite tous les
deux la bienvenue dans notre commission
donc Félix Gérard pour ce qui est de la
commission des finances puis ensuite je
passerai la parole au rapporteur des
groupes et aux autres commissaires
monsieur le ministre chez Olivier vous
avez la parole
merci beaucoup madame la présidente
monsieur le rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs les députés comme l'a dit
madame la Présidente à l'instant en
septembre dernier j'ai sollicité des
partenaires sociaux l'ouverture d'une
discussion en vue de la conclusion d'un
accord national interprofessionnel
relatif au partage de la valeur dans les
entreprises c'est un accord que nous
avons souhaité et qui a fait l'objet de
discussion accord qui a abouti le 10
février dernier avec un texte qui a
recueilli la majorité des signatures en
l'occurrence les trois organisations
professionnelles représentatives et
quatre des cinq organisations syndicales
représentatives
le projet de loi que je vous présente
est un projet de loi de transcription
dans la loi des dispositions de l'accord
avec la volonté de respecter de manière
intégrale et fidèle les dispositions de
l'accord et ce projet de loi a été
adopté par le Conseil des ministres le
24 mai dernier et il débute son
cheminement parlementaire avec
l'audition par votre commission par son
contenu le projet de loi
issu de cet accord s'inscrit en réalité
dans la lignée des réformes menées
depuis 2017 pour revaloriser le travail
et notamment améliorer le partage de la
valeur la loi pacte de 2019 a permis de
simplifier la mise en place d'accord
d'intéressement et de participation dans
les PME et l'attractivité du régime
social de ces dispositifs un
parallèlement été renforcé pour les
petites entreprises je pense aussi à la
loi qui porte mesures d'urgence pour la
protection du pouvoir d'achat voté en
juillet 2022 publié en août 2022 qui
permet de faciliter davantage encore le
recours à l'intéressement dans les PME
et d'instaurer une nouvelle prime de
partage de la valeur après la prime
exceptionnelle de pouvoir d'achat
cette prime améliorée concrètement le
pouvoir d'achat des Français puisqu'elle
a bénéficié à 5,5 millions de salariés
en 2022 pour un montant total distribué
de près de 4,4 milliards d'euros plus
généralement lorsque l'on regarde les
dispositifs de partage de la valeur tel
qu'ils existent et notamment une
dispositif d'intéressement et de
participation les compléments de
rémunération apportées via ces
différents dispositifs c'est levé en
2020 à 2440 euros par salarié dans les
entreprises de plus de 10 personnes
c'est une moyenne bien évidemment cela
représente un total de 19 milliards
d'euros ce qui fait notre pays le
deuxième pays européen à faire le plus
usage preuve qu'il y a comme un modèle
français à au partage de la valeur et à
cette volonté de revalorisation du
travail
ceci étant pourrait être si précis
possible avant de venir au contenu du
texte que je vous présente je voudrais
souligner que les partenaires sociaux
ont tenu à faire figurer dans
un principe en tête de cet accord pour
rappeler que le partage de la valeur est
les revenus issus du partage de la
valeur ne se substitue pas au salaire et
je le répète donc devant vous la
rémunération du travail tient d'abord et
avant tout au salaire il est dispositifs
de partage de la valeur n'ont pas
vocation assez substituées nous ne
faisons aucune confusion nous savons
l'importance d'être exigeant et sur le
partage de la valeur d'une part et sur
la question des négociations salariales
d'autre part ce sont d'ailleurs deux
objectifs qui ne sont pas incompatibles
mais deux outils plutôt complémentaires
sur le sujet des salaires et unis
mercredi 14 juin mercredi dernier le
comité de suivi des négociations
salariales ce qui est aussi important
puisque nous sommes dans une période de
forte inflation que le SMIC a été
revalorisé trois fois en 2022 deux fois
cette année en 2023 et puisque nous
avons fait le choix de remettre les
grilles salariales à la responsabilité
du dialogue social il est important de
garantir le bon dynamisme de la
négociation qui est le meilleur garant
de la croissance des salaires et des
grilles face à l'inflation
en réalité pour revenir au projet de loi
de transposition de l'accord la volonté
de partager la valeur créée par les
entreprises répond je crois deux
demandes importantes des Français
d'abord œuvrer encore davantage pour le
pouvoir d'achat des salariés pour faire
face à l'inflation et répondre à une
demande plus forte de participation des
salariés dans la marge de leur
entreprise une aspiration est de
valorisée et mieux entendu ce qui
rejoint d'ailleurs un désir démocratie
au travail le mécanisme les mécanismes
partagent de la valeur notamment la
participation et l'intéressement ne sont
évidemment pas des mécanismes nouveaux
et nous le rappelons souvent c'est en
fait le programme du général de Gaulle
qui a défini et posé les fondements du
partage de la valeur tel que nous
l'entendons ainsi dès 1948 il propose le
régime de l'association avec la volonté
de partager les résultats le capital et
la gouvernance de l'entreprise et je le
cite de telle sorte que chacun participe
directement aux résultats de
l'entreprise à laquelle il apporte son
effort
c'est sur son manque seront créé les
intéressements et l'épargne salariale
puis les lois oraux de 1982 permettront
d'approfondir ces mécanismes de partage
aujourd'hui par ce projet de loi issu de
l'accord conclu par les partenaires
sociaux nous proposons finalement de
poursuivre cette tradition et d'aller
plus loin aller plus loin car si les
mécanismes sont anciens l'usage de ces
dispositifs de partage de la valeur
restent trop inégale ainsi si 70% des
salariés des entreprises de plus de 100
salariés disposer d'un accès à un
dispositif de participation 2020 seul 3%
de ces entreprises de moins de 9
salariés et 6% de ceux des entreprises
content entre 10 et 49 salariés il y
avait taxé de fait les entreprises de
moins de 55 salariés nous le savons ne
sont aujourd'hui pas soumises à
l'obligation de mise en place de la
participation
nous avons donc souhaité aller plus loin
pour développer le partage de la valeur
dans ces petites entreprises notamment
dans celles de moins de 50 salariés mais
aussi pour faciliter généraliser leur
usage dans toutes les entreprises
lorsque nous regardons l'accord signé
par les partenaires sociaux nous
engageons à le respecter leur de sa
transposition dans la loi je l'ai dit il
y a un instant j'ai invité en septembre
2022 les partenaires sociaux à envisagé
et engagé cette négociation nationale
interprofessionnelle pour améliorer les
dispositifs de partage de la valeur pour
les généraliser dans les entreprises et
le document d'orientation qui
accompagnait cet engagement à la
négociation les invités à négocier pour
renforcer le partage de la valeur en
travail capital au sein des entreprises
et améliorer l'association des salariés
aux performances de l'entreprise
le dialogue social s'est ouvert il n'a
pas été interrompu pendant toute cette
période et il a permis d'aboutir un
accord ainsi la Henni a été conclu le 10
février 2023 il a été signé je disais
par les trois organisations patronales
représentatives le Medef la CPME et
l'u2p et par 4 des 5 organisations
syndicales représentatives la CFDT la
cfdtc est faux et la cFECGC je veux
devant vous saluer leur travail et leur
esprit de consensus c'est la preuve que
ce dialogue permet de construire des
solutions concrètes consensuelles au
bénéfice des Français sur des sujets qui
font l'objet d'une forte attente de leur
part
c'est la raison pour laquelle je
présente ce texte devant vous avec un
principe simple l'accord et rien que
l'accord nous sommes engagés lors
d'ouverture de la discussion elle aura
transcrire fidèlement et c'est ce que
propose le texte aujourd'hui d'ailleurs
pour garantir cette fidélité à l'accord
notre méthode a été de concerter et de
co-construire ce texte à chaque étape de
son élaboration et je souligne là aussi
alors que votre commission va désormais
examiner le texte d'abord pour saluer
les travaux déjà menés pas en
particulier par votre apporteur mais
aussi par d'autres députés je pense
madame et Madame evassa en particulier
mais aussi par souci de cohérence pour
répéter que nous souhaitons que
l'équilibre du texte soit conservé cela
ne signifie pas qu'il n'y a pas
d'amélioration à apporter au texte mais
je souhaite et le gouvernement souhaite
par ma voix que lorsqu'il y a
amélioration lorsqu'il est la
modification du texte nous puissions
faire en accord avec les signataires de
l'accord et sur la base d'un consensus
entre les organisations syndicales et
patronales signataires de cet accord
vous le savez aussi certaines
stipulations de l'accord ne sont pas
dans le projet de loi en tant que tel
cela a été souligné par certains des
partenaires sociaux signataires et à
raison c'est parce que nous considérons
qu'il s'agit de mesure qu'il nécessite
pas de disposition législative elles
peuvent être dans réglementaires elles
peuvent être de la pratique ou être
satisfaite par le droit je pense
notamment aux principes de non
substitution mais je pense aussi que
nous pouvons la trouver des motifs et
des pistes d'amélioration
[Musique]
ensuite ce projet de loi permet de
développer les dispositifs existants de
partage de la valeur dans les petites et
les moyennes entreprises il facilite le
développement de la participation dans
les entreprises de moins de 50 salariés
qui ne sont pas soumises à l'obligation
de mise en place d'un dispositif de
participation en permettant de négocier
par accord de branche dans l'entreprise
des formules dérogatoires à la formule
légale de participation la formule
légale peut constituer parfois un frein
en développement du partage de la valeur
dans ces petites entreprises et l'accord
permet de lever ce frein pour cela le
texte permet la négociation de formule
de participation dérogatoire à la
formule légale dans les entreprises de
moins de 50 salariés et ainsi la base de
calcul retenu pourra être par exemple un
pourcentage du bénéfice net fiscal ou du
résultat comptable avant impôt
permettant ainsi une réserve spéciale de
participation supérieure ou inférieure à
ce que prévoit la formule légale ce qui
est une souplesse de plus pour ces
entreprises de moins de 50 salariés
parmi les dispositions les plus
marquantes de ce projet de loi et
au-delà de celle-ci je souhaite
simplement en évoquer trois devant vous
d'abord les entreprises de 11 à 50
salariés auront jusqu'au 31 décembre
2024 pour mettre en place un dispositif
de partage de la valeur dès lors
qu'elles ont un bénéfice un bénéfice
bénéfice pardon Netflix fiscal positif
supérieur à 1% de leur chiffre
d'affaires pendant trois années
consécutives les partenaires sociaux
ainsi affirmés qu'il n'y a pas de raison
que les entreprises de plus de 50 de
plus de 50 salariés doivent absolument
mettre en œuvre un dispositif de partage
de la valeur et pas celle de moins de 50
salariés qui le peuvent il y avait là un
manque et cet accord puis le projet de
loi propose de le combler ensuite les
entreprises de plus de 50 salariés
soumises à l'obligation de mise en place
d'un dispositif de participation auront
jusqu'au 30 juin 2024 pour négocier des
conséquences en termes de partage de la
valeur dans les entreprises en cas de
bénéfices exceptionnel et enfin
souligner que l'exonération fiscale
applicable pour les salariés dans la
rémunération est inférieure à 3 SMIC sur
la prime de partage de la valeur créée
par la loi du 16 août 2022
que ce dispositif d'exonération sera
prolongé jusqu'au 31 décembre 2026 dans
les entreprises de moins de 5 ans de
salariés sont des mesures importantes
pour généraliser les dispositifs de
partage de la valeur aux petites
entreprises et revenir sur l'inégalité
de fait qui existe en la matière entre
les salariés des petites et les grandes
entreprises enfin ce projet de loi
propose de créer de nouveaux outils et
permet de rénover certains dispositifs
existants
par exemple le projet de loi crée le
plan de partage de la valorisation de
l'entreprise durer d'une durée de 3 ans
mise en place par accord pour l'ensemble
des salariés ayant au moins un
anciennetés il permet aux salariés de
bénéficier d'une prime dans le cas où la
valeur de l'entreprise a augmenté sur
ces trois années de durée sur les trois
années de la durée du plan c'est un
outil innovant qui permet d'intéresser
financièrement les salariés à la
croissance de valeur de leur entreprise
et aussi les fidéliser à l'échelle de
cette durée c'est la rapproche donc
l'intérêt des salariés des propriétaires
d'entreprises des actionnaires et
puisqu'il bénéficient en même temps de
la valorisation de celle-ci
le projet de loi facilite aussi
l'utilisation de la prime de partage de
la valeur dont j'ai dit le succès il y a
un instant par exemple les entreprises
pourront verser jusqu'à deux primes par
an au lieu d'une seule et la prime pour
être versée sur un plan d'épargne
salariale pour permettre salarié de
bénéficier d'une exonération fiscale
pour les sommes bloqués de manière
générale les articles 9 à 12 prévoient
une série de simplification et
d'assouplissement avec par exemple la
sécurisation du versement d'avance par
trimestre pour la participation et
l'intéressement et enfin le projet de
loi développe l'actionnariat salarié
c'est là une réponse claire des
partenaires sociaux la demande d'une
plus grande participation et ainsi le
projet permet notamment l'ouverture
d'une plus grande portion du capital aux
salariés actionnaires avec
l'augmentation des plafonds de versement
d'action gratuite aux salariés il permet
aussi la promotion d'une épargne verte
solidaire et responsable avec dans le
cas des plans d'épargnomme d'entreprises
et retraite d'entreprise qui devront
proposer au moins un fond financant la
transition écologique ou socialement
responsable par ailleurs l'amélioration
de la gouvernance des fonds
d'actionnariés salariés est prévu en
obligeant un plus de transparence sur la
politique d'en
ce projet de loi participe ainsi à deux
objectifs d'une part un objectif de fond
améliorer le partage de la valeur et
permettre d'avoir accès à plus de
pouvoir d'achat pour les salariés
concernés et un deuxième objectif de
méthode qui est la fidélité à une
transcription intégrale de l'accord
conclu par les partenaires sociaux je le
répète pour terminer madame la
Présidente Monsieur rapporteur mesdames
et messieurs les députés tout au long de
l'examen du texte et notamment lors de
son examen en séance nous veillons pour
ce qui concerne le gouvernement a
toujours appuyé notre avis sur le
consensus des signataires de cet accord
comme nous l'avons fait d'ailleurs pour
expliquer ou accompagner la présentation
de ce projet de loi de quelques nuances
ou modulation par rapport au contenu
exact de l'accord et seul à la suite de
la vie du Conseil d'État c'est cette
méthode de fidélité à l'accord et à
l'engagement des signataires que je vous
propose de respecter avec nous
très bien merci bien monsieur le
ministre je passe la parole donc à
monsieur le rapporteur Louis Marguerite
pour une durée de
5 minutes d'habitude
si vous dépassez un peu bon ben tant pis
allez-y monsieur le monsieur le
rapporteur
merci Madame la prison
on va s'adapter merci beaucoup à ma
présidente monsieur le ministre madame
la rapporteur pour avis chers collègues
d'abord merci de votre accueil dans la
Commission de la commission des affaires
sociales associer les salariés aux
fruits de la croissance des entreprises
pour mieux répartir les richesses c'est
un principe sur lequel repose ce partage
de la valeur levier essentiel un des
leviers essentiels de la valorisation du
travail de fidélisation et de motivation
des salariés facteurs de compétitivité
des entreprises et vecteurs de justice
et de cohésion sociale c'est une idée
très gaulienne héritée du général de
Gaulle les années 1950 et 1960 les
dispositifs de partage la valeur ils
sont nombreux complets peut-être parfois
complexe c'est vrai intéressement
participation pandépins de salariales ou
encore opération d'actionnaires salariés
ils sont très largement réparateurs
répandus en France en 2019 seul la
Slovénie faisait mieux à l'échelle du
continent que nous et nous pouvons nous
féliciter d'être en tête de gondole sur
ce sujet les années récentes ont
d'ailleurs été marqués par un
déploiement continu le nombre de
salariés couverts par l'un de ces
dispositifs à très nette progresser au
cours de ces quatre dernières années
entre 2017 et 2020 plus de 8% avant que
la crise sanitaire évidemment ne vienne
rebattre un peu les cartes c'est pour
ces progrès sont imputables bien sûr à
la volonté des des salariés et des chefs
d'entreprise en mais également à
l'action résolue de la majorité
présidentielle et du gouvernement qui
s'est employé dès le début de la
précédente législature a créé les
conditions de leur diffusion dans les
entreprises petites et moyenne en
particulier avec la loi du 22 mai 2019
la loi pacte que nous connaissons bien
ou la loi plus récente du 16 août 2022
dites loi pouvoir d'achat nombre de
mesures pragmatiques ont été mises en
oeuvre à cette fin entre simplification
normative et incitation fiscale
il ne reste pas moins vrai que les
salariés bénéficient dans des
proportions très différentes de toutes
ces dispositifs et force est de
reconnaître que c'est cela reste
l'apanage des moyennes et surtout des
grandes voire des très grandes
entreprises en 2020 39% des salariés des
entreprises de 50 à 99 salariés avec
accès à la participation et 25% à
l'intéressement quand plus de 70% des
salariés des entreprises de plus de 1000
salariés et plus avaient accès à l'un
comme à l'autre il y a donc des marges
de progrès réelles et substantiels ainsi
soucieux de prolonger les efforts déjà
accomplis du gouvernement invité les
partenaires sociaux à l'automne 2022
vous lavez rappelé monsieur le ministre
a engager une négociation nationale
interprofessionnelle sur le partage de
la valeur entre travail capital qui
était orienté autour de trois axes les
généralisations de l'accès à un outil de
partage de la valeur sans changer les
fondements de ces différents outils
l'amélioration et l'articulation à leurs
différents outils nous le verrons dans
l'examen du texte et l'orientation de
les parcs salariale vers les grandes
priorités d'intérêts communs
sur la base de ce canevas que vous aviez
mis en place et au terme de plusieurs
semaines de discussion sans doute
plusieurs mois les organisations
syndicales de salariés les organisations
patronales ont conclu le 10 février 2023
un accord national interprofessionnel
sur le partage de la valeur au sein de
l'entreprise il est riche de 36 articles
il faut vraiment s'en féliciter parce
que cet accord est historique il y avait
au début de cette négociation assez peu
de chances qu'ils y arrivent les uns
considérant que ce n'était pas le sujet
les autres considérant qu'il n'y avait
pas de sujets ils ont trouvé un terrain
d'attente sur un sujet aussi fondamental
c'est vraiment la preuve que la
démocratie sociale se porte bien dans
notre pays qu'elle a de beaux jours
devant nous
si c'est vrai on en reparlera le présent
projet de loi est sur la transposition
la transposition des circulations de la
nuit dont la mise en oeuvre suppose
notre intervention conformément à
l'engagement pris pas la première
ministre je dis avec toute ma conviction
son examen au Parlement est dans notre
assemblée devra se faire dans le respect
des grands des partenaires sociaux afin
que les grands équilibres soient
préservés ces quelques éléments de
contexte je peux rendre sans rentrer
dans le détail rappeler les différents
titres qui composent cette ce texte
d'abord un premier titre qui est un
article unique qui s'impose à toutes les
branches qui n'ont pas procédé depuis 5
ans un examen de leur classification une
négociation sur le sujet afin la fin de
l'année 2023 un titre 2 qui rassemble
toutes les dispositions qui pour objet
de faciliter la généralisation de ces
outils de partage de la valeur avec en
particulier l'article 3 qui est une
vraie avancée une vraie avancée pour les
entreprises de 11 à 49 salariés qui qui
est conçu sous la forme
d'expérimentation et pour une durée de
cinq ans et qui qui suppose que les
entreprises de 11 à 49 salariés qui
dégage des bénéfices nous reviendrons
dessus puissent distribuer en tout cas
un des trois outils de partage de la
valeur un des dispositifs phares de la
corne national transposée articles 5
c'est l'obligation de mieux partager les
résultats d'une augmentation
exceptionnelle de bénéfices au sein des
entreprises de 50 salariés et plus qui
compte au moins délégué syndical ce sont
près de 8000 entreprises qui sont
potentiellement concernées par cette
mesure et cela va donc bien au-delà des
seuls grands groupes je rappelle que
c'est un point de vigilance des
organisations syndicales dans un
contexte économique ou sans cette ou
certains secteurs de l'énergie ou des
transports réalise des profits élevés
nous avons débattu depuis un an que nous
sions au sein de cette institution il
est normal que nous puissions nous poser
la question que les salariés reçoivent
une juste part à la contribution lorsque
les entreprises dégagent des bénéfices
le dispositif le dispositif initialement
envisagé par les partenaires sociaux
confiés au seul employeur le son de
définir ce qu'est une augmentation
exceptionnelle des bénéfices face au
risque d'incompétence négatif de
législateur le projet de loi que vous
avez modifié dans une saisie de
requificative monsieur le ministre a
entendu confié la négociation collective
à cette mission toutefois pour tenir
compte des réserves émisses par le
Conseil d'État il semble que la
définition puisse voir être ajustée et
cela fera l'objet des discussions que
derrière qui vont se tenir dans les
prochaines minutes ou les prochaines
heures entre l'ergonie organisation
syndicale et organisation patronales
quelques mots sur l'article 6 qui
complètent le mécanisme de la prix du
prime de la prime ne partage de la
valeur que cette assemblée a voté il y a
maintenant près d'un an et qui provoque
jusqu'à 2026 fin 2026 sa composante
exceptionnelle en soutien au pouvoir
d'achat des seules entreprises de moins
de 50 salariés c'est un outil qui est
plébiscité par les chefs d'entreprise il
nous semble qu'il convient de le
conserver ces mesures sont naturales
conforter sur le succès de la BPV qui a
bénéficié en 2022 à 25% des salariés du
secteur privé pour un montant de 4,4
milliards d'euros
il y a également quelques articles sur
la création d'un outil un outil nouveau
sur lequel nous reviendrons l'article 7
sur le plan de partage de valorisation
de l'entreprise qui nous semble être un
outil intéressant qui vise à mieux faire
partager la croissance de valeur sans
ajuster les droits de gouvernance
quelques articles 8 de coordination et
ensuite l'article 3 le titre 3 pardon
qui proje loi qui contient plusieurs
mesures de simplification que les
partenaires sociaux ont appelé de leurs
vœux notamment la sécurisation d'accord
d'intéressement et également la
simplification des procédures de
révision de plan des panneaux
inter-entreprise pour ne citer que celle
là enfin l'objet du titre 4 du projet de
loi permet de mettre un point d'honneur
à favoriser l'actionnaire salarié qui
est également un outil très efficace
d'association des salariés à
l'entreprise et notamment permet de
rehausser les plafonds d'attributions
d'actions gratuites les Agats vous
l'avez également évoqué monsieur le
ministre
nous nous aurons nous aurons évidemment
le temps de revenir sur ces différents
articles je voudrais simplement vous
dire que les partenaires sociaux avaient
très largement remplir leur mission
c'était des discussions difficiles nous
avons auditionné à plusieurs reprises
avec ma collègue et Vassas que je
voudrais remercier pour la qualité des
travaux que nous avons mené ensemble
dans la mission d'information également
les administrateurs de l'assemblée qui
font un travail formidable et dire que
c'est à nous de remplir la nôtre pour
nous montrer la hauteur de l'enjeu et
montrer que la démocratie sociale peut
être vaut au moins autant que la
démocratie parlementaire je vous
remercie merci bien monsieur le
rapporteur je passe je passe la parole
cette fois-ci à Madame Félicie Gérard
rapporteur pour avis allez-y madame
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues je me réjouis d'être
parmi vous aujourd'hui la commission des
finances c'est en saisie pour avis de ce
projet de loi portant transposition de
l'année de l'année du 10 février 2023
relatif au partage de la valeur au sein
de l'entreprise comme l'a dit notre
collègue Louis Marguerite cette année
est un cette année est un succès à
mettre au crédit du dialogue social dans
notre pays signé par la majorité des
organisations syndicales et patronales
représentative il témoigne de la force
de la démocratie sociale et de
l'ambition qu'il est possible d'avoir
dans ce cadre sur mon initiative la
commission des finances a jugé utile de
se saisir pour avide des titres 2 et 4
de ce projet de loi ce texte est porteur
de nombreux progrès il développe la
participation dans les petites
entreprises il renforce le partage de la
valeur lorsque les résultats financiers
favorables des entreprises le permettent
il accompagne le développement de la
prime de partage de la valeur et enfin
il développe l'actionnariat salarié en
début d'après-midi l'examen en
commission des finances aura permis de
rappeler notre volonté collective de
transposer fidèlement cette année seules
amendements que j'avais déposés ont été
adoptés l'un pour étendre le rapport
prévu à l'article 2 un examen plus large
des modalités de calcul de la
participation et l'autre pour transposer
dans la loi l'article 33 de l'année
vous l'aurez compris je soutiens
pleinement la transcription de cet
accord cette année démontre que le
dialogue entre employeur et salarié
fonctionne dans notre pays ce dialogue
est souhaitable et bénéfique pour tous
notre rôle de législateur est à mon sens
de l'accompagner et de l'encourager je
vous remercie merci bien je passe la
parole à présent aux orateurs de groupe
et je passe pour Renaissance la parole à
Michel perron
oui oui merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers collègues le projet
de loi soumis à notre étude est avant
tout un texte issue d'un accord de
l'ensemble des organisations patronales
et des organisations syndicales
signataires sur le sujet du partage de
la valeur ou même plus précisément des
résultats c'est ainsi que le
gouvernement nous présente le texte à
travers une transposition la plus
respectueuse des équilibres trouvés par
les organisations professionnelles
représentatives de notre pays la France
se fait figure d'exemples au sein de
l'Europe en effet la France dispose d'un
arsenal conséquent de partage de la
valeur que ce soit de la participation
de l'intéressement ou de l'épargne
salariale
notre pays s'est doté de mécanismes
visant à valoriser les salariés d'une
entreprise lorsque celle-ci a de bons
résultats si ces dispositifs sont plus
répandus au sein des grands groupes
l'objet de l'année et de ce texte était
de permettre à ces mécanismes de se
généraliser en particulier dans les TPE
et les PME qui représentent ainsi un
grand nombre de salariés aujourd'hui un
1500 000 à peu près aussi ce texte
prévoit notamment la mise en place d'une
négociation sur la prise en compte des
résultats exceptionnels dans les
entreprises d'au moins 50 salariés ou
encore l'instauration d'ici janvier 2025
pour les entreprises de 11 à 49 salariés
d'un dispositif de partage de la valeur
dont le choix se fera entre l'accord de
participation l'accord d'intéressement
le versement d'une prime de partage de
la valeur ou l'abondement à un plan
d'épargne salariale parmi les autres
dispositions présentes au sein de ce
texte l'article 6 prévoit de maintenir
le régime fiscal et social de faveur de
la prime de partage de la la valeur
initialement en vigueur jusqu'au 31
décembre 2023 de manière pérenne pour
les entreprises de moins de 50 salariés
ce texte est donc un texte qui vient
entériner un accord désorganisation
syndicales et patronale nous nous devons
de le respecter la majorité a toujours
soutenu la démocratie sociale ainsi le
groupe Renaissance fidèle à ses
engagements auprès des organisations
professionnelles soutiendra ce texte
monsieur le ministre quel a été la
méthode pour aboutir à ce projet de loi
quels seront les suites à donner à cet
acide merci merci bien Monsieur Frédéric
cabrolier pour le rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre l'accord national
interprofessionnel qui a été voté en
février 2023 voit 15 de ses 35 ou 36
articles transposés dans ce projet de
loi alors on retrouve la possibilité de
négocier un accord de participation
d'ici juin 2024 avec une liberté totale
sur la fixation de la formule du calcul
de la partition qui peut être moins 10
ans que la formule légale ce qui doit
permettre d'étendre la participation
dans les entreprises de moins de 50
salariés on retrouve la volonté de faire
bénéficier aux salariés des bénéfices
exceptionnels de leur entreprise qui
entend répondre à une question de
justice sociale l'inscription dans le
temps également et dans le champ de
l'épargne salariale de la prime de
partage de la valeur en temps répondre à
une problématique de pouvoir d'achat
l'augmentation des plafonds de capital
attribua pour les attributions d'action
gratuites devraient contribuer à
l'objectif affiché de 10% d'actionnariat
salariés dans le capital des entreprises
françaises à horizon 2030 toutefois
certaines remarques nous ont été
formulés lors des auditions comme le
fait que le nouveau plan de valorisation
de l'entreprise qui consiste à
intéresser financièrement les salariés à
la croissance de la valeur de leur
entreprise vient en concurrence avec
l'actionnariat salarié qui est plus
compliqué à mettre en œuvre il faut
rappeler également que le développement
de ces outils de partage de valeur ne
doit pas se faire détriment de
l'augmentation des salaires qui restent
le meilleur partage de la valeur en
effet le CNRS nous a rappelé que la
participation et l'intéressement
représentent 6% de la masse salariale
dans les entreprises où elles ont été
mises en place et un tiers ont eu un
impact négatif sur les augmentations de
salaire enfin les chiffres du partage de
la valeur sont faussés par la pratique
de la fraude fiscale évaluée à 40
milliards d'euros et il y a rien dans ce
projet de loi sur ces dispositions et
bien sûr tout ça
grève la participation des salariés et
je terminerai en disant que le Conseil
d'État également a fait quelques
remarques notamment sur les entreprises
pour la PPV de moins de 50 salariés qui
est prolongé on l'a dit jusqu'à fin 2026
il fait remarquer que cette barrière des
50 salariés porte atteinte à l'égalité
des salariés devant les charges
publiques selon qu'ils appartiennent à
une entreprise de plus ou de moins de 50
salariés je vous remercie très bien la
parole est à Monsieur mathiestavel pour
la France insoumise du Pesse
monsieur le ministre vous êtes des
hypocrites et tout le monde le sait vous
êtes des hypocrites parce que vous vous
cachez derrière cet accord national
interprofessionnel comme alibi de
démocratie sociale alors que vous venez
d'écraser les syndicats les manifestants
à l'Assemblée nationale pour imposer la
retraite à 64 ans vous êtes des
hypocrites parce que vous versez des
larmes de crocodile sur le soi-disant
déficit des retraites mais vous
présenter un projet de loi qui va encore
affaiblir la sécurité sociale par des
exonérations de cotisations sur
l'intéressement la participation ou les
primes vous êtes des hypocrites car vous
instrumentalisez ce texte pour faire
croire que vous faites quelque chose
pour le pouvoir d'achat des Français
alors que vous ne faites rien pour
augmenter les salaires ni bloquer les
prix mais votre texte est en aveu l'aveu
de l'échec de la prime Macron d'abord
70% des salariés ne l'ont pas touché
l'aveux aussi de l'aggravation de la
prédation du capital sur le travail la
France est championne d'Europe des
dividendes versées aux actionnaires mais
pendant ce temps les salaires réels ont
baissé en 2022 et les sous-traitants
sont par les donneurs d'ordre entendant
ou bien qu'une entreprise distribue une
partie de ses bénéfices à ses salariés
et la moindre des choses mais ce texte
repose sur une illusion dangereuse pour
les salariés car les niches sociales et
fiscales au profit des primes de
l'intéressement et de la participation
sont des pouces au crime anti salaire et
antisecus les salariés sont ainsi
invités à se serrer la ceinture pour
espérer percevoir une partie du bénéfice
que leur travail gratuit aura constitué
mais après que les actionnaires se sont
servis du plus gros morceau cette
désocialisation comme vous l'appelez est
une arnaque d'ailleurs partagée entre
macroniste et le pénis pour nous le
Parlement n'est pas la seule chambre
d'enregistrement ni des désirs du
monarque Élysée un nid des miettes
consenti à être lâché par le MEDEF au
contraire nous avons besoin d'une vraie
loi pour la hausse des salaires et pour
le partage des richesses pour assurer
enfin l'égalité salariale homme-femme
pour augmenter le SMIC pour indexer des
salaires sur l'inflation pour instaurer
un écart maximum de rémunération dans
les entreprises de 1 à 20 pour limiter
le versement de dividendes au profit des
salaires bref en un mot pour mettre fin
à votre préférence actionnariale et
imposée la priorité salariale et sociale
que les Français réclament
très bien monsieur le député quand on a
du savoir-fuivre au moins on salue ses
collègues et monsieur le ministre c'est
la moindre des choses alors vous dites
qu'on est des hypocrites mais vous vous
manquez de savoir-vivre la parole est à
Monsieur Stéphane Viry pour les
républicains
très bien
mes chers
[Musique]
collègues nous aurons l'occasion au
cours des débats de revenir sur les
articles de ce projet de loi sur les
amendements moi l'état de nos
discussions je considère que ce projet
de loi est utile car il permet de poser
un débat peut-être qu'il va au-delà de
la conformité de cette année sur
globalement un sentiment que j'ai depuis
un an qui a une opposition systématique
entre les salariés et les chefs
d'entreprise entre le capital et le
travail moi je considère qu'il faut
aller au-delà que la France a su le
faire jadis à plusieurs reprises et il
est temps de reprendre une vision
golienne qui avait mis en exergue la
participation et l'intéressement des
salariés et au-delà de cette idée de
sortir un peu de cette de ce monde qui
s'affrontent je pense effectivement que
ce projet-là il permet d'évoquer la
question du pouvoir d'achat dans un
contexte inflationniste très élevé alors
que manifestement le pouvoir d'achat est
une préoccupation majeure voire
prioritaire des Français cet accord
national interprofessionnel il est le
fruit de discussion utiles et fructueuse
il faut s'en féliciter après que le
dialogue je l'ai eu à souffrir d'un
manque de considération pendant de
nombreux mois et trop souvent a été
relégués aux oubliettes il s'agit pour
un homme et chers collègues de
transcrire un accord national
interprofessionnel moi pour ma part avec
mes collègues les républicains on a un
principe de responsabilité législative
de conformité il ne s'agit pas pour nous
effectivement de chercher à faire
autrement
on a effectivement l'idée qu'il faut
aller donner un complément de
rémunération qu'il faut également donner
un complément de challenge aux salariés
c'est-à-dire d'aller chercher à quelque
chose à partager de façon collective
notamment les résultats de l'entreprise
après j'aurais peut-être trois
observations trois trois réserves par
rapport à votre projet de loi tout
d'abord sur l'actionnariat salarié
monsieur le ministre j'ai un peu le
sentiment que c'est le parent pauvre de
ce projet de loi et que ce projet de loi
aurait pu nous permettre d'aller bien
au-delà également sur l'épargne
salariale je trouve que son affectation
est un peu maigre des projets d'intérêt
commun il en existe mais là encore un
manque d'ambition selon moi des
entreprises font déjà beaucoup et ils
lui étaient à mon avis nécessaires
d'afficher une am bition majeures et
puis troisième objection les salariés
des entreprises de moins de 11 salariés
qui eux effectivement sont totalement
absents alors que ça constitue de très
nombreux citoyens et citoyennes qui sont
en emploi de notre société française
très bien la parole est à Madame Anne
bergande pour le groupe démocrate modem
et indépendant
monsieur le ministre madame la
présidente monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames et Messieurs chers collègues
quand il s'agit d'économie tout n'est
pas une affaire de Chypre de pourcentage
et de statistiques certes la politique
gouvernementale a réussi à tenir ses
objectifs avec un taux d'emplois
historiquement élevé et un nombre de
chômeurs qui n'a jamais été aussi bas
depuis des décennies cependant des
chiffres ne seraient donné pleine et
entière satisfaction s'ils ne
s'accompagne d'une réelle volonté de
donner du sens au travail de participer
à sa juste reconnaissance et de partager
équitablement les fruits aujourd'hui la
transposition de Lagny constitue un
nouveau contrat de répartition des
richesses dans l'entreprise créant les
conditions d'un équilibre plus bénéfique
aux salariés aux travailleurs comme au
chef d'entreprise c'était équilibre
fruit de longue négociations entre les
organisations syndicales et patronales
nous avons tenu à l'honorer au groupe
démocrate en ne présentant qu'un seul
amendement négocier avec les dernières
sociaux et commun en trois groupes de la
majorité pour une meilleure
compréhension j'aurais pour vous
monsieur le ministre une remarque
question et deux questions d'abord
concernant le principe de non
substitution en vertu duquel les sommes
versées au titre du partage de la valeur
ne doivent pas se substituer au salaire
en effet il peut y avoir une confusion
entre épargne salariale et renforcement
du pouvoir d'achat des salariés chez
certains acteurs avez-vous une
clarification à apporter sur ce sujet
même si vous en avez déjà un petit peu
parlé dans votre propos liminaire
Lagny ensuite prévoyait la mise en place
d'un plan de communication nationale
envisagez-vous de le mettre en place
également et enfin concernant l'article
4 du PJL à défaut du délai antérieur de
3 ans de combien de temps disposeront
les entreprises concernées pour mettre
en place un dispositif de participation
aucun nouveau délai n'a en effet été
précisé ni dans la ni dans le PJL
monsieur le ministre je vous remercie
par avance pour vous éclaircissements
merci merci bien la parole est à
Monsieur Jérôme Guedj pour le groupe
socialiste et apparenté dupes je vous
donne le micro monsieur le député
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre vous retrouver dans sa
commission des affaires sociales
c'est toujours délicat pour les
parlementsaires que nous sommes en tous
les cas moi je le vis comme tel d'opérer
la transposition d'un ami sans jeux de
mots c'est il y a 10 ans l'anniversaire
d'un autre ami dont nous avions eu à
débattre à l'époque Monsieur le Ministre
celui sur le marché du travail à chaque
fois le parlementaire qui ont un accord
entre partenaires sociaux sont
questionnés légitimement entre la marge
de manœuvre qui doit et qui peut être la
leur ici elle est étroite d'abord parce
que vous avez fait le choix de
transposer certains des articles il
faudra nous expliquer pourquoi certains
ne l'ont pas été retenus alors vous avez
dit qu'il n'était pas de nature
législative on verra assez vite par
exemple dès l'article premier qu'il
faudrait peut-être de manière utile
réintroduire la référence au métier
référence justement dans l'article
premier qui a disparu de la
transposition ou à l'article 5 sur le
versement automatique du supplément de
participation d'intéressant en cas de
bénéfice exceptionnel donc ça c'est la
première difficulté c'est les choix que
vous avez fait de transposition ou de
pas ou de ne pas transposer puis la
deuxième difficulté c'est que on aurait
très envie nous de débattre d'un projet
de loi de partage de la valeur mais en
ayant choisi ce titre de transposition
du PJL de Lagny alors on s'est vu
écarter beaucoup de propositions qui
auraient été utiles dans le débat
peut-être peut-être n'aurait-elle pas
été retenu mais puisqu'on parle de
partage de la valeur nous nous aurions
aimé parler de revalorisation des
salaires notamment d'augmentation du
SMIC ou d'une conférence nationale sur
les salaires de tirer le bilan de la
réforme de la loi pacte et notamment de
la réforme de la participation notamment
les modes de calcul des effectifs
d'instaurer un ratio d'écart salarial
maximum au sein des entreprises de
conditionner les exonérations sociales
au respect d'indicateur de partage alors
vous allez me dire c'était pas dans la
négociation mais les parlementaires
auraient eu envie de pouvoir débattre de
ceci et de pouvoir je termine par une
question du coup parce que dans cette
petite marge étroite que vous nous
offrez entre démocratie sociale et
démocratie parlementaire vous a eu cette
phrase à l'instant monsieur le ministre
en nous disant j'espère que chacun des
amendements pourra recueillir l'accord
des partenaires sociaux signataires et
donc la question c'est comment allons
nous faire quel est le juge de paix quel
est celui qui est le garant de savoir si
il y a accord ou pas encore allons nous
suspendre nos travaux à l'examen le
rapporteur
je vous laisse le temps nécessaire donc
surtout que c'est une question que je
pose à Monsieur le Ministre pour la
qualité des travaux qui est de savoir
comment est-ce qu'on va faire en
commission et en et en séance pour
savoir si les amendements que nous
déposons il y a pas de critères de
recevabilité avec une commission
composée des signataires de l'année donc
qui est le juge de paix
votre question Monsieur François
Gernigon pour le groupe horizon et
apparenté merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur ministre chers collègues je
tiens à souligner en premier lieu la
démarche adoptée par les partenaires
sociaux dans leslaboration donc de cet
accord national interprofessionnel et le
soutien apporté par le gouvernement
suite aux efforts entrepris pour
faciliter l'accès à l'intéressement dans
les PME et renforcer la prime Macron en
été 2022 vous aviez exprimé votre
volonté d'aller plus loin c'est dans ce
contexte que s'inscrit la nuit preuve
d'une volonté commune d'approfondir
l'inclusion des salariés dans la
valorisation de leur entreprise en
particulier dans un contexte
socio-économique exigeant
la nuit répond un double objectif
améliorer la répartition de la valeur
créée et mieux récompenser les salariés
en cas de performance exceptionnelle des
entreprises ils permettra également
d'inclure davantage des salariés dans
les bénéfices de l'entreprise
l'article 3 du projet de loi qui engage
les entreprises de plus de 11 salariés à
mettre en place un dispositif de partage
de la valeur laissant une liberté de
choix quant à son type participation
intéressement PPV abonnement à un plan
d'épargne salariale constitue une
avancée notable en faveur de la justice
au sein des entreprises
en outre l'accord encourage à instaurer
un système de participation ajoutant un
autre levier pour rééquilibrer le
partage des bénéfices au sein de ces PME
il insiste également sur l'importance de
considérer les résultats exceptionnels
des entreprises en prévoyant un
versement automatique supplémentaire de
participation ou d'intéressement ou en
incitant à un dialogue sur le partage de
la valeur
cependant le texte ne précise
volontairement pas ce qui serait
considéré comme une augmentation
exceptionnelle des résultats comme prévu
par l'accord d'où ma question monsieur
le ministre comment le gouvernement
envisage-t-il le cadrage de la
définition des résultats exceptionnels
afin d'assurer la bonne mise en oeuvre
du principe de partage de cette valeur
je vous remercie merci bien madame et
Vasas pour le groupe écologiste nupes
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues concernant
cette transposition de Lagny partage de
la valeur je voudrais insister sur
quatre points tout d'abord ce projet de
loi ne répond en rien au problème de
pouvoir d'achat des Français le premier
outil de partage de la valeur c'est bien
l'augmentation des salaires et ce
devrait être votre priorité car le
salaire réel diminue depuis le 3e
trimestre 2021 et encore perdu 1% sur la
dernière année ensuite oui il faut
favoriser l'accès des salariés des
entreprises de moins de 50 salariés aux
outils de partage à valeur pour lutter
contre ce salariat à deux vitesses d'un
côté les salariés des grands groupes
déjà les mieux rémunérés et bénéficiant
de la participation et de
l'intéressement et de l'autre les
salariés des tpeme qui n'ont que très
peu accès à ces outils mais la portée de
ce projet de loi est malheureusement
très faible et ce pour trois raisons
d'abord vous avez introduit la prime
Macron dans les outils de partage la
valeur alors que celle-ci a un effet de
substitution aux augmentations de
salaire à hauteur de 30% en moyenne
selon l'Insee deuxièmement il n'y a
aucun minimum fixé dans la loi si fait
qu'il sera possible un employeur de
verser une prime de 1 euro pour
satisfaire ses obligations légales et
enfin concernant le versement d'une
prime exceptionnelle quand l'entreprise
réalise des résultats exceptionnels il
n'y a dans ce projet de loi qu'une
obligation de négocier et rien n'est
prévu si la négociation échoue dernière
chose vous auriez dû à l'occasion de ce
projet de loi vous attaquez aux
employeurs peu scrupuleux qui privent
les salariés de leurs droits à
participation en déplaçant la valeur
ajoutée dans des holdings en France ou à
l'étranger vous n'en avez rien fait dès
lors j'aurai deux questions monsieur le
ministre allez vous donner un avis
favorable à nos amendements qui abrogent
l'article l3326-1 du Code du travail un
article qui n'a qu'un seul but protéger
les patrons qui privent les salariés de
leur juste participation comme chez
Procter un Gumball McDonald's ou General
Electric et deuxièmement si vous souciez
vraiment du partage à valeur pourquoi ne
pas avoir initié une négociation
interprofessionnelle non pas sur le
partage à valeur mais sur les salaires
c'est ce qu'attendent des millions de
Français qui n'arrivent pas à boucler
leurs fins de mois
merci bien Monsieur Pierre dareville
pour le groupe GDR dupes
merci madame la Présidente comme je
pressens qu'il va y avoir un certain de
soirée mousse autour de ce projet de loi
je voudrais quand même vous redire que
il y a une défiance syndicale de très
haut niveau quand même qui demeure dans
le pays notamment à l'égard du
gouvernement et que lorsque Monsieur le
Rapporteur nous dit tout à l'heure que
la démocratie sociale vaut autant que la
démocratie parlementaire je ne donne pas
très cher ni de l'une de l'autre en
réalité et je ne m'y résoudre pas ceci
étant dit il va se produire également
aussi beaucoup de théories autour de
cette notion de partage de la valeur et
je crois que le projet de loi ne met pas
fin à l'accompagnement des à
l'acaparement des richesses par
quelques-uns elle a financarisation de
l'économie le partage de la valeur se
pose dans l'entreprise il se pose aussi
au sein de la société tout entière
je crains que autour de l'actionnariat
salarié vous ne cherchez à entretenir
une sorte d'illusion qu'il suffirait en
réalité à abolir la contradiction entre
le capital et le travail dans
l'entreprise ce dont je ne suis
absolument pas convaincu pour ne pas
dire les choses de manière plus tranchée
et cela introduit aussi potentiellement
un biais dans le rapport au travail et à
l'entreprise mais je crois qu'il ne fera
pas illusion
le gouvernement depuis 6 ans maintenant
fait du contournement du salaire un
sport favori et de ce point de vue là on
n'y est pas et je crois que lorsque
monsieur le ministre vous nous indiquez
que
l'idée qu'il ne peut pas y avoir de
substitution entre ces mécanismes et la
question salariale je crois que ça
appelle véritablement des dispositions
concrètes et des mesures et il ne s'agit
pas d'un bavardage et c'est pas inscrit
dans la nid juste pour décorer et nous
nous devons essayer de regarder comment
nous pouvons traduire de façon
législative des garanties de ce point de
vue là enfin les dispositifs de partage
de la valeur repose sur un nombre
croissant d'exonération de cotisations
sociales et qui vont effectivement privé
la sécurité sociale de ressources dont
elle aurait amplement besoin donc tous
ces sujets mériteraient d'être débattus
dans les échanges que nous allons avoir
dans les temps qui viennent
merci bien alors nous allons passer
cette fois ci aux questions de députés
je passe tout de suite la parole pour
deux minutes à Madame Charlotte
Parmentier Lecoq merci madame la
Présidente je voudrais d'abord saluer
l'engagement de monsieur le ministre
d'avoir soutenu encouragé ses
négociations d'avoir permis qu'elle
puisse se lancer et aboutir et puis
saluer le travail rapide que vous avez
pu avoir avec les rapports pour élaborer
un projet de loi qui rapidement puisse
transposer ce texte et donc apporter des
mesures efficaces de partage de la
valeur valider par l'ensemble des
partenaires sociaux des mesures qui vont
permettre que lorsque l'entreprise gagne
et bien les salariés gagnent aussi alors
les partenaires sociaux ont quand même
bien rappelé la primauté que doit avoir
la rémunération de base sur ces
différentes mesures complémentaires dans
le projet de loi d'ailleurs vous avez
prévu une obligation de négociation sur
les salaires lorsqu'ils n'ont pas été
renégociés depuis cinq ans
dans la loi pouvoir d'achat on avait
aussi ajouté la possibilité pour le
gouvernement de faire fusionner des
branches qui seraient peu allante sur
les négociations sur les salaires
inférieurs au SMIC et vous même vous
êtes très engagé dans le suivi de ces
négociations donc je souhaiterais avoir
votre avis sur l'efficacité de ces
différentes mesures et sur la dynamique
que vous pouvez observer dans dans ce
comité de suivi des différentes
négociations dans les branches
merci bien la parole est à Madame Annie
Vidal merci madame la Présidente merci
monsieur le ministre pour cette
transposition rapide de l'accord
national inter-branche dans un projet de
loi c'est essentiel pour notre pays
alors je voudrais quand même attirer
votre attention sur les mesures
incitatives pour encourager les
entreprises à adopter des dispositifs de
partage de la valeur qui sont proposés
dans ce texte il est indéniable que ce
partage de la valeur est un enjeu majeur
Majeur en favorisant largement
l'engagement des entreprises nous
pouvons renforcer la cohésion sociale et
notre croissance économique déjà
soutenue grâce à notre action mais aussi
stimuler l'innovation bien qu'adhérent
au principe certaines entreprises en
particulier les petites et les moyennes
entreprises peuvent rencontrer des
difficultés pour mettre en place ces
dispositifs je souhaiterais donc que
vous nous préciser
quelles sont les mesures incitatives
prévues pour les encourager à s'engager
dans cette démarche quel dispositif
d'accompagnement de conseils comment les
aider à mieux comprendre les avantages
et les modalités de mise en oeuvre de
ces dispositifs et comment les
sensibiliser au bénéfice de partage de
la valeur je vous remercie de ces
précisions merci bien Monsieur Victor
Catteau merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur alors que notre pays connaît
une inflation galopante une perte de
pouvoir d'achat inédite et que les
salaires augmentent que très peu voire
pas du tout vous avez monsieur le
ministre récemment imposé aux Français
le travail jusqu'à 74 ans et ce dans les
conditions que je viens de citer
conscient que vous alliez avoir du mal à
faire avaler la pilule aux Français vous
avez fait la demande en dernier
certainement dans un énorme bonté que
les partenaires sociaux de notre pays se
réunissent et engage des discussions
du gouvernement aurait alors pu
s’arrêter là en demandant aux
organisations syndicales à notre pays
d'ouvrir des discussions sur le sujet
que tous les Français attendent au vu de
la situation économique que nous
connaissons mais qui semble constituer
une véritable boîte de Pandore à vos
yeux les salaires mais non à défaut
d'avancer sur ce sujet capital vous leur
avez demandé de discuter des dispositifs
de partage de la valeur en entreprise
mesure certes utile en termes de
redistribution et de pouvoir d'achat
mais qui semble plus faire office de
pansement à l'heure actuelle qu'une que
d'une véritable solution et oui monsieur
ministre comme l'a rappelé Lagny dans
son préambule le salaire doit rester la
forme essentielle de reconnaissance du
travail fourni par les salariés et des
compétences mises en cet effet la
première ministre c'était alors engagée
à proposer une transcription fidèle et
totale de la nid dans la loi là encore
des mensonges la macronie elle est tout
de même pas faire l'effort de respecter
ses promesses et enfin écouter les
Français dans votre projet de loi pas
d'effort sur la simplification du
forfait social pour t'en demander par la
nid dans son article 11 pas de précision
de la notion du caractère aléatoire dans
les accords d'intéressement voulu à
l'article 15 et pas de précision sur ce
que constitue un bénéfice exceptionnel
pour une entreprise ce qui a même été
déploré par le Conseil d'État c'est
pourquoi monsieur le ministre je vous
demande quand elle est vous enfin
prendre la question du pouvoir d'achat
des Français véritablement au sérieux en
cessant enfin de tourner autour du pot
et en abordant la problématique centrale
qui préoccupe nos concitoyens celle des
salaires je vous remercie
merci Monsieur Arthur de la porte
merci madame la Présidente alors mon
collègue Jérôme Guedj saluait tout à
l'heure un anniversaire celui de
l'accord national interprofessionnel
l'année de 2013 permettez-moi de saluer
un autre anniversaire celui de notre
élection il y a un nom
il y a un an la première ministre a
obtenu la confiance d'une majorité
relative de notre assemblée sur une
promesse celle de la nouvelle méthode
une méthode fondée sur le dialogue sur
le compromis elle se revendiquait
aujourd'hui on a eu l'occasion d'avoir
une présidente de l'Assemblée aussi qui
se revendiquait d'une forme de
social-démocratie
qu'est-ce que la Nice sinon finalement
la reconnaissance de la prééminence du
dialogue social en matière de droit du
travail
force et de constater que finalement ici
on a plutôt
promu une forme de nivellement du
dialogue social par le bas puisque ce
que vous nous proposez ici c'est
finalement rien de moins que transposer
mais juste transposer sans même nous
donner le pouvoir à nous les
parlementaires mais nous y sommes
habitués finalement à cette
impossibilité de débattre ici ce que je
ne comprends pas c'est commander un côté
vous pouvez mépriser le dialogue social
ce que vous avez fait pendant plusieurs
mois et même finalement depuis un an et
demi avec la réforme de l'assurance
chômage puis la réforme des retraites et
puis aujourd'hui changer de braquer et
vous faire les parangons de cette pseudo
nouvelle méthode alors finalement ma
question sera simple Lagny pourquoi la
nuit n'aurait-elle pas le même sort que
la niche liotte c'est à dire cadenasser
dévitalisé finalement à l'image de ce
qui vous préoccupe depuis le début de la
législature c'est-à-dire mépriser tout
ce qui s'apparente de près ou de loin à
une forme de construction saine et
démocratique voilà donc au-delà de cette
année-croche je me permettrai de dire
que ce que nous souhaitons ici c'est des
débats parlementaires animés mais
vivants et donc je vous demanderai
également de permettre cette expression
et à l'avenir de vous engager monsieur
le ministre à écouter au delà d'être
syndicats que nous souhaitons les
parlementaires dans leur proposition ce
que vous n'avez manifestement pas fait
depuis un an Aurélie retrouver pour deux
minutes
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre en soi on peut se féliciter que
viennent un projet de loi sur le partage
de la valeur puisque le contexte il est
celui d'une inflation extrêmement
importante mais surtout une inflation
qui mène à une baisse des salaires réels
de 3% en 2022 et même une baisse du
pouvoir d'achat que votre politique de
petit chèque n'a pas réussi évidemment à
endiguer un partage de la valeur qui se
fait de plus en plus au service c'est
des chiffres d'insey suffit de regarder
l'Insee c'est par ailleurs un partage
qui se fait de plus en plus en faveur
des actionnaires et on le voit avec
aujourd'hui l'évolution extrêmement
favorable du versement en matière de
dividende alors moi j'ai cette question
puisque il s'agit vous dites qu'il
s'agit de partage de la valeur à quel
moment pensez-vous vous préoccuper des
salaires puisque ce n'est pas dans ce
projet de loi et comment d'ailleurs
peut-on nommer un projet de loi qui ne
s'occupe pas des salaires mais qui
s'occupent de tous les dispositifs sauf
des salaires en fait votre proposition
de favoriser le les dispositifs de
partage de la valeur il y a bien une
substitution au salaire qui se produira
l'Insee le montre là également c'est 30%
de la prime Macron qui se substitue au
salaire soit une perte de 1,2 milliards
d'euros en un an pour les salariés donc
moi j'ai cette question vous dites il ne
s'agit pas de substitution du salaire
qu'est-ce qui garantit dans ce projet de
loi qu'il n'y aura pas de substitution
des salaires vous parlez ensuite de
revalorisation du SMIC il n'y a pas de
revalorisation du SMIC de votre part
qui soit au-delà des dispositions
légales c'est bien pour ça que nous nous
demandons une hausse du SMIC au-delà de
l'inflation et puis j'en arrive
maintenant au salaire au salaire
eux-mêmes
et aux écarts de salaire et de
rémunération au sein des entreprises
puisqu'on sait que ces écarts augmentent
considérablement que l'écart de la
rémunération entre les dirigeants et les
salaires moyens au sein des entreprises
sont en forte augmentation là aussi à
quel moment puisque ce n'est pas dans ce
projet de loi manifestement à quel
moment comptez-vous vous attaquez au
problème donc moi je constate que vous
avez voulu à travers ce projet de loi et
après la réforme des retraites montrer
que peut-être vous vous préoccuperiez de
partager mais en réalité il n'y a rien
sauf la Peur
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre ce projet de loi relative au
partage des valeurs au sein de
l'entreprise va créer encore une fois de
plus en plus plus une division en
tétravoya une récompense pas le travail
à la hauteur de sa valeur en effet ce
qui travaille pour les grandes
entreprises avec un peu de chance se
verront accorder des primes plus élevées
que les salariés des plus petites
entreprises car certaines PME TPE sous
l'une déjà leur situation financière
contrainte par la conjoncture pour
expliquer l'absence de versement de
prime ce sera notamment le cas pour les
outre-mer exemple pour la réunion les
entreprises sont très majoritairement de
petites tailles et compte entre 1 et 9
salariés très peu d'entreprises ont plus
de 11 salariés et c'est plus ou moins la
même situation dans les autres
territoires
d'outre-mer à votre avis monsieur le
ministre qu'elle est en pourcentage le
nombre d'entreprises et de salariés qui
seront concerné par cette mesure dans
les outre-mer en août cette politique de
prime se situe à une vraie politique
d'augmentation des salaires et de
manière spécifique puisque le pouvoir
d'achat est beaucoup plus bas chez nous
dans nos territoires ne faut-il pas
appliquer un SMIC majoré en outre-mer un
SMIC de rattrapage qui selon une étude
boosterait la consommation des ménages
et contribuerait à tonifier les
économies en outre-mer quelle est votre
avis monsieur le ministre merci bien et
bien après ces nombreuses interventions
et questions je passe la parole à
Monsieur le Ministre
je vous remercie merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
députés sont nécessairement répondre
intervenant par intervenants et je vais
essayer de reprendre les principaux
points qui ont été évoqués pour éviter
les redites d'abord une question sur la
méthode lorsque nous avons engagé les
partenaires sociaux à ouvrir cette
discussion beaucoup d'entre eux avaient
exprimé le souhait que cette ouverture
discussion soit accompagnée d'un
engagement du gouvernement sur une
transposition intégrale et fidèle de
l'accord engagement que j'avais prié
engagement que la première ministre a
pris à son tour et que nous respectons
ici j'entends un certain nombre
d'interventions qui soient parce que la
question des salaires n'est pas abordée
au-delà des classifications c'est
notamment l'intervention de Madame SAS
soit parce que les questions d'épargne
salariale d'actionnariat salariés ou
de la question des entreprises de moins
de salariés ne sont pas traitées de
manière extrêmement approfondie c'est le
cas de Monsieur Viry peuvent exprimer
une forme de frustration de déception
je peux comprendre et je peux entendre
un certain nombre de ces interventions
de ces arguments mais ne pas respecter
l'engagement que nous avons pris
vis-à-vis des partenaires sociaux qui
ont accepté d'ouvrir cette discussion
serait à mon sens pire c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous faisons ce choix de
transposer de manière intégrale et
fidèle tout à l'heure monsieur guedjman
m'a demandé comment est-ce que l'on va
vérifier veiller à la conformité ou à
l'accord ou consensus des signataires
d'abord permettez-moi de rappeler une
évidence c'est que les parlementaires
sont évidemment libres de déprécier tous
les amendements qu'il souhaite dans les
règles de recevabilité l'habit du
gouvernement sera appuyée sur une
consultation des partenaires sociaux sur
les amendements qui ont été déposés et
libre à chaque parlementaire de vérifier
auprès des signataires que la vie que je
donnerais en m'appuyant sur le recueil
de leur propre avis et bien conforme
mais c'est ce que nous avons commencé à
faire et il y a un certain nombre de
sujets qui ont été évoqués sur lesquels
je crois que nous allons pouvoir avancer
d'ici la séance il a été évoqué à
plusieurs reprises le principe de non
substitution il est fixé il est rappelé
et il est précisé
du Code du travail je crois que tous les
signataires de l'accord et au-delà
d'ailleurs considère que la solidité
juridique du principe de non
substitution tels qui arrêtée par le
code du travail et tout à fait
satisfaisante si d'ici la séance nous
pouvons en accord avec les signataires
trouver une rédaction qui s'en remettre
en cause la solidité de cet article du
code du travail permettre de
réintroduire ce principe de non
substitution pour que le texte de loi
soit aussi équilibré avec l'accord j'y
serai évidemment favorable sur la
question que vous avez aussi évoquée
monsieur le député des métiers référents
nous considérons que ces satisfait par
le droit existant c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous n'avons pas introduit dans
le texte mais nous aurons certainement
cette discussion à l'occasion de la
science et si là aussi des rédactions
consensuelles peuvent permettre de le
conforter tant mieux mais en l'état du
droit et j'aurai l'occasion de le dire
si les amendements étaient ainsi déposés
cela nous paraît satisfait les
dispositions de l'accord stipulation de
la corps plus exactement nous n'avons
pas intégré dans le projet de loi
sont soit de leur réglementaire soit
nous paraissent satisfaire en état du
droit et nous n'avons pas voulu prendre
le risque de la répétition le Conseil
d'État monsieur cabri la rappelé ainsi
que Monsieur Gernigon et d'autres
intervenants
émis un certain nombre de remarques des
remarques concernant la question de
l'égalité devant l'impôt pour ce qui
concerne la prorogation du dispositif du
régime fiscal et social particulièrement
avantageux de la prime de partage de la
valeur dans les entreprises de moins de
50 salariés nous avons pris à acte
évidemment de ces remarques mais par
engagement à la fidélité de la
transposition nous avons maintenu malgré
la vie du Conseil d'État ces
dispositions soumises à votre vote de la
même manière quand c'est d'État fait des
remarques sur la manière dont on
caractérise un résultat exceptionnel
dans une entreprise cela occasionné
puisque les remarques ont été faites à
l'occasion du premier examen en section
c'était occasionné une saisie
rectificative et je précise que la
saisie rectificative du Conseil d'État
que nous avons fait sur
cette condition et se renvoi est
négociation d'entreprise sur la
définition des caractères exceptionnels
a été faite fidèlement à la méthode que
j'ai évoquée c'est à dire que les termes
de la saisine rectificative ont été
partagés et de manière consensuelle avec
les signataires de l'accord le Conseil
d'État dans son assemblée générale a
considéré que les précisions pouvaient
manquer et l'avis du Conseil d'État
renvoie à un certain nombre de
précisions utiles sur la taille de
l'entreprise sur le niveau moyen des
bénéfices au cours des dernières années
ou encore les secteurs d'activité nous
travaillons là aussi avec les
partenaires sociaux signataires de
l'accord pour voir quel serait les
dispositions qui pourraient recueillir
un soutien consensuel de leur part
il a aussi été évoqué la question du
dispositif appelé plante valorisation
des entreprises ou plan d'intéressement
à la valorisation d'entreprise avec un
risque de concurrence avec le système
d'actionnariat salarié je pense que ces
dispositifs sont plutôt complémentaires
que concurrents le dispositif proposé
par les partenaires sociaux ne prévoit
pas l'attribution de part sociale du
capital mais simplement un intéressement
à l'augmentation de la valeur globale de
l'entreprise dans des conditions de mise
en oeuvre beaucoup plus simple que
l'actionnariat salarié qu'il faut bien
le convenir est un dispositif difficile
à mettre en place donc je pense que
c'est complémentaire et je ne pense pas
qu'il y ait de concurrence ou de
cannibalisation entre les deux puisque
le régime fiscal et social de ce plan de
valorisation est le même que celui lié à
la perception de revenus liés à des
plans d'actionnariat salarié
sur les questions relatives à l'accès
aux outils et à la popularisation en
tout cas au partage par un maximum
d'entreprises des outils qui sont prévus
par l'accord je pense que un plan de
communication est nécessaire l'état
prendra évidemment sa part dans le plan
de communication et je pense que les
organisations professionnelles les
branches en particulier doivent le faire
j'ai souhaité et j'ai rencontré cet
après-midi le président du conseil
d'administration de l'URSSAF je souhaite
qu'un groupe de travail soit rapidement
mis en place et sans préjugés évidemment
du mode du Parlement pour que la
direction générale du travail les
urssafs puissent avancer sur la manière
dont on met en place les outils les
éléments de communication permettant à
chacun de s'approprier les éléments de
l'accord je pense que les ambassadeurs
que nous avons mis en place en termes
d'intéressement partage de la valeur
peuvent être utilement mobilisés et je
pense que ces ambassadeurs peuvent et
doivent en tout cas je le souhaite et
c'est un point que nous avons évoqué
travailler sur la manière dont les
dispositions de la Cour nationale
interprofessionnelle peuvent être mises
en œuvre dans les territoires
ultramarins il y a des caractéristiques
sociales et économiques de ces
territoires des caractéristiques liées à
la taille moyenne des entreprises dans
les territoires ultramarins des
caractéristiques liées aux spécificités
des régimes fiscaux et sociaux je pense
notamment à la prise en compte des
caractéristiques liés à Notre-Dame qui
nécessitent qu'un travail particulier
soit mené par je pense les ambassadeurs
de l'intéressement de la participation
pour que les territoires ultramarins
puissent être bien inclus dans la mise
en œuvre de ces différentes dispositions
a posé la question pardonnez-moi parce
que je viens désormais sur des points
peut-être plus ponctuels des
simplifications en matière de forfait
social je dois dire que c'est un des
points de l'accord que nous n'avons pas
traduit inscrit dans la loi dans la
mesure où nous considérons que là aussi
c'est satisfait puisque depuis 2019 il
n'y a plus de forfait social sur la
participation dans les entreprises de
moins de 5 ans de salariés là où ce
dispositif participation est facultatif
et qu'il n'y a plus de forfait social
sur l'intéressement dans les entreprises
de moins de 250 salariés et en cela ces
mesures de 2019 ainsi que les
facilitations mises à la conclusion
d'accord d'intéressement dans la loi du
16 août 2022 nous paraissent très
largement répondre à ces stipulations de
l'accord
beaucoup d'intervenants ont évoqué la
question
des négociations salariales je renvoie
un principe et je sais que ça ne
satisfera pas nécessairement l'ensemble
des intervenants et des intervenants sur
le sujet nous considérons que la loi et
cela a été rappelé permet une indexation
du SMIC sur l'inflation et notamment sur
l'inflexe l'inflation connue par le
premier des cils des ménages français
ainsi que sur l'évolution d'un certain
nombre d'indicateurs quant aux salaires
moyen horaire notamment du salaire moyen
ouvrier et nous renvoyons de manière
constante ça n'est pas une nouveauté ce
gouvernement la détermination du niveau
des salaires au dialogue social de
branche sioxe social de bronches est
suivi par le comité le comité de suivi
des négociations salariales que j'ai
réuni le 14 juin dernier il y a quelques
jours quels sont les effets c'est la
question de Madame Parmentier Lecoq des
dispositions que nous avons adopté que
vous avez adopté pardon avec la loi du
16 août 2022 ce sont des effets
bénéfiques puisque si depuis le 1er mai
évidemment un grand nombre de branches
pour moi un minima conventionnel
inférieur au SMIC ce nombre est
important du fait de la revalorisation
récente du SMIC le recul de quelques
mois que nous avons notamment par
rapport à la revalorisation du SMIC au
1er janvier montre que les choses sont
accélérées en l'espace de 4 mois donc le
1er janvier et la fin du mois d'avril
sur les à peu près 140 branches qui ont
eu un minima conventionnel inférieur au
SMIC du fait de leur valorisation du
SMIC au 1er janvier 77 avait fait ce
travail de mise en conformité
77 en l'espace de quelques semaines
quatre mois c'est beaucoup plus rapide
que ce que nous connaissions
précédemment et par ailleurs vous avez
adopté un certain nombre de dispositions
qui permettent au gouvernement de
considérer que le maintien pendant une
période trop longue d'une branche dans
une situation où elle présente au moins
un minima inférieur au SMIC est un
critère de restructuration deux éléments
de réponse à cela le premier pour dire
que lorsque nous regardons le nombre de
branches dont un minima conventionnel au
moins est un ferrovs depuis plus d'un an
nous sommes à neuf aujourd'hui sur les
171 suivi
contre 20 en moyenne lors des années
précédentes et enfin cette possibilité
de restructuration en cas de maintien
long d'une branche avec un minima
conventionnel l'intérieur au SMIC nous
l'actionnons puisque j'ai indiqué à la
branche des casinos que faute d'accord
d'ici au mois de septembre puisque c'est
le délai de procédure contradictoire si
je puis dire prévu par la loi du 16 août
2022 nous procéderons la restructuration
cette première exemple de mise en œuvre
de la disposition de la loi du 16 août
pour le reste j'espère ne pas avoir
oublié trop de points je pardonnais moi
je parcours rapidement
mes notes non je termine simplement en
disant que
de manière générale je comprends et
j'entends qu'il y a toujours une forme
d'insatisfaction à ne pas aller au-delà
de l'accord tel qu'il a été noué par les
partenaires sociaux c'était le cas je
crois lors des discussions autour de
l'ANI en donner lieu une transposition à
l'été 2021 en matière de santé au
travail ça peut être le cas évidemment
avec cette énigme comme ça avait été le
cas avec la ni 2013 qui a été rappelé
d'ailleurs à Igny qui donne un certain
nombre de résultats probants puisque
parmi les dispositions de cette année
figurait notamment des conventions de
revitalisation dispositif qui a
l'occasion de sa dixième année montre
aussi son efficacité pour accompagner la
réindustrialisation et la création de
nouvelles activités sur les territoires
directement concernés par des plans de
restructuration et et des plans sociaux
voilà madame la Présidente que je
pouvais dire je ne doute pas que le
débat que nous aurons en séance
permettra d'avancer et je répète la
totale disponibilité du gouvernement
pour continuer à améliorer ce texte avec
toujours cet élément de méthode que je
souligne la volonté qui est la de nous
conformer à la fois l'accord mais aussi
à un consensus des partenaires sociaux
signataires cet accord pour les
modifications qui seraient envisagées à
l'occasion de cette discussion
merci bien monsieur le ministre pour
toutes ces réponses
précises qui n'appelle pas de remarques
émanant des députés donc encore une fois
merci je remercie également les
rapporteurs et puis mes chers collègues
nous allons donc nous retrouver puisque
nous allons rentrer dans le dur à 21h je
dis bien 21h et pas 21h30 ce soir
c'était pour prévu pour 21h moi ça me
dérange pas mais bon
ah on me dit que les députés ont des
choses voilà ils avaient prévu certaines
choses donc du coup c'est pas possible
donc
moi je peux pas permettre de démarrer
mettez-vous d'accord qui est pour
bon et bien ma foi nous allons commencer
donc je suspends juste une minute le
temps de dire au revoir au ministre donc
nous venons d'achever la l'audition du
ministre et la discussion générale donc
en fin d'après-midi elle nous abordons
donc désormais l'examen des articles du
projet de loi portant transposition de
l'accord national interprofessionnel
relatif au partage de la valeur au sein
de l'entreprise inscrit alors du jour de
la séance publique à compter donc de
lundi prochain avant de commencer il me
revient de vous donner quelques
précisions sur le nombre d'amendements
en discussion alors il y a 317
amendements qui ont été déposés un a été
déposé d'ailleurs en double un qui
modifiait donc les dispositions
réglementaires et six ont été retirés
par leurs auteurs le président de la
commission des finances a estimé que 34
amendements étaient contraires à
l'article 40 et au dispositions de la
lolse je précise que la plupart de ces
amendements pourront être recevables en
séance pour peu qu'il soit correctement
gagé pour ma part j'ai tenté d'appliquer
au mieux l'article 45 en laissant le
plus possible la place à l'initiative
parlementaire ce qui m'a néanmoins
conduit à devoir déclarer 62 amendements
et recevables je rappelle que le projet
de loi ne porte pas sur l'ensemble de
l'anime et seulement sur certaines de
ces dispositions les amendements ne
devaient donc pas seulement avoir un
lien avec la nid mais avec les
dispositions de la nie reprise dans le
projet de loi par conséquent je n'ai pas
pu considérer comme recevable des
amendements tendant à imposer par
exemple un tiers ou la moitié de
salariés au conseil d'administration
harmoniser le périmètre de publication
de la rémunération moyenne des salariés
de l'entreprise ou encore permettre par
exemple à l'expert comptable d'accéder
aux lias fiscal de l'entreprise donner
des moyens aux experts-comptables
mandatés par les comités sociaux
économiques de confronter les
entreprises à leur pratique
d'optimisation de groupe
mais aussi augmenter le taux minimal de
majoration des heures supplémentaires
pour le travail à temps partiel il y
avait aussi un sujet sur la
revalorisation des salaires des
apprentis et déclarés aussi et recevable
au titre de l'article 45 demandez la
présentation d'un rapport par exemple
sur l'entrepreneuriat féminin encadré
également les versements de dividendes
majorer le prélèvement forfaitaire
unique etc etc donc il y a eu plusieurs
irrecevabilités à ces titres là ça
s'agissant plus particulièrement des
amendements en lien avec l'article 1 je
rappelle que cet article conduit à
l'ouverture du négociation par branche
sur la nécessité de réviser les
classifications pour les branches qui ne
l'ont pas fait depuis 5 ans et que cette
négociation prend en compte l'objectif
de mixer comme vous le savez les
classifications servent à déterminer
l'intégralité de la grille
au travers des minimas hiérarchiques les
amendements visant à renforcer la
négociation collective sur les éléments
sur les éléments en lien indirects avec
les classifications m'ont donc paru
recevables par exemple quand ils portent
sur la négociation sur tous les salaires
sur l'intégralité des grilles ou des
minimas ou bien sur la mixité en
revanche les amendements qui avaient
pour but d'administrer les salaires ne
m'ont pas assemblé recevable comme se
fixant le SMIC une rémunération minimale
ou une échelle de salaire ou bien sûr
établissements un lien entre le SMIC et
salaire minimum des salariés d'une
branche de même les amendements dont
l'objet principal est de revenir sur les
allégements généraux de cotisations ou
certaines aides n'ont pas de lien même
indirect avec le texte et donc j'ai bien
sûr dû les déclarer irrecevables alors
pour autant mes chers collègues il ne il
nous reste quand même 208 amendements à
examiner donc qui sont en discussion
donc nous allons pouvoir démarrer cet
examen alors avec amendement portant
article additionnel avant l'article 1 et
je passe tout de suite la parole à
Madame Maximy
pas de problème allez-y je vous donne le
micro vous l'avez oui bien sûr à travers
notre amendement nous voulons tout
simplement et là je le chant du titre
premier au dialogue social sur les
rémunérations en matière de partage de
la valeur nous nous opposons à la
défense permanente du gouvernement au
sujet des rémunérations et nous
constatons que même dans ces tits ce
projet de loi fait pour fait tout pour
éviter les hausses de salaire en
incitant notamment à recourir à la prime
exceptionnelle de pouvoir d'achat et en
généralisant les dispositifs
d'intéressement et de participation
exonérer de cotisations sociales ces
mécanismes viennent faire une
concurrence déloyale a durées
augmentations de salaire ainsi je le
rappelle par cet amendement nous
proposons de réaffirmer les objectifs du
dialogue social et des négociations en
matière des classifications mais aussi
en matière de rémunération
très bien monsieur le rapporteur votre
avis sur cet amendement oui je crois
qu'on est on est au cœur d'une
discussion qu'on aura sans doute dans
les prochains amendements les prochains
articles qui est effectivement la
question des salaires versus les autres
compléments de rémunération je vais
appeler comme ça même si c'est
probablement pas le terme tout à fait
totalement pertinent moi je vous propose
qu'on en parle peut-être sur les sur les
articles on sera vraiment au cœur de
cette question juste en deux mots le
projet de loi d'ailleurs ça a été dit
par le ministre et on l'a rappelé les
questions des salaires a été écartées
par les partenaires sociaux
organisations syndicales et
organisations professionnelles personne
n'a dit d'ailleurs que ce projet de loi
réglé la question de l'augmentation des
salaires on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler sur effectivement les
dynamiques salariales versus les
dynamiques de pouvoir d'achat c'est
évidemment au coeur des préoccupations
je suis pas sûr par ailleurs que les
titres changeraient d'ailleurs quelque
chose à la à cette question donc pour
ces raisons sur cet amendement comme le
suivant d'ailleurs qui lui ressemble je
suis défavorable
très bien oui monsieur le député
merci monsieur le rapporteur en l'espèce
justement si les titres sont importants
il s'agit bien de montrer la volonté du
législateur que la discussion la
négociation qui va avoir lieu sur cette
base ne se limite pas au seul
classification mais intègre la question
des rémunérations et ça nous paraît
absolument évident y compris si on veut
faire en sorte que c'est classifications
derrière n'aboutissent pas à ce que des
personnes restent plusieurs années à un
niveau du SMIC parce que les minimas
seraient trop bas ou parce qu'il n'y
aurait pas eu la discussion aussi sur
les rémunérations à ce moment-là donc ça
nous paraît tout à fait nécessaire de le
mettre ce serait d'ailleurs au passage
une manière de prouver votre bonne foi
quand vous dites que vous ne voulez pas
de la substitution de ces autres formes
de rémunération par rapport au salaire
si vous ne le voulez pas alors faisons
en sorte que la discussion qui va
s'ouvrir porte aussi sur les
rémunérations moi pour ma part je ne
connais aucune organisation syndicale de
salariés qui ne seraient pas d'accord
pour ouvrir une négociation de branche
che sur les salaires très bien monsieur
le rapporteur
j'entends vos points mais simplement en
l'occurrence c'est le seul article c'est
comme ça c'est la discussion qui est
issue de la discussion qui a eu entre
les organes et son patronales et
syndical pas de doute quand ils ont dû
être pas simple enfin j'imagine et ça a
été rappelé ils ont mis beaucoup de
temps et on pensait d'ailleurs au début
quels allaient pas y arriver donc on
reviendra aussi sur cette notion là en
l'occurrence celle qui touche à la
grille des salaires c'est le seul
article de la ligne et donc du projet de
loi qui évoque cette question là donc
c'est pour ça que le titre refait bien
référence à la question des
classifications et pas à d'autres
éléments qui pourraient toucher à la
grille salariale la dynamic salariale
j'entends votre point je pense qu'on
aura plein d'autres articles et d'autres
amendements sur lequel on reviendra sur
ce sur ces débats de fond que j'entends
mais mais je mais je reste défavorable
bien monsieur le député vous maintenez
je suppose votre amendement monsieur
Ratenon ou monsieur Tavel oui oui très
bien je mets aux voix cet amendement qui
a reçu un avis défavorable de monsieur
le rapporteur qui est pour
qui contre il est rejeté
article premier
amendement pouvant être mis en
discussion comme une alors qui le prend
madame Maximy
je sais pas si vous êtes
madame SAS pardon et excusez-moi c'est
moi qui vous confond pardon madame SAS
pardon allez-y
merci d'avoir la Présidente c'est un
amendement qui vise à apprendre en
compte les métiers repères dans la
révision des classifications car c'est
la meilleure façon de mettre en lumière
les écarts femme homme les métiers les
mieux rémunérés étant le plus souvent
majoritairement
occupé par des hommes je voudrais
rappeler à ce titre que la corne
nationale interprofène du 10 février
relatif il faut partager la valeur au
sein de l'entreprise prévoit qu'il
convient d'apprécier les niveaux de
rémunération regarde non seulement des
classifications mais aussi des métiers
repères
très bien pardon un autre amendement
monsieur Guedj oui merci madame la
Présidente ben on est là immédiatement
dans un cas d'espèces de la qualité de
la transposition alors on va rentrer
dans la philosophie même si comme l'a
dit le ministre tout à l'heure c'est un
beau débat que celui de l'articulation
entre démocratie sociale et
démocratie parlementaire mais
glissons-nous dans le cahier des charges
pour proposer celui de la transposition
de Lanie toulani rien que la nuit au
moment où vous nous proposez donc une
révision des classifications
pour tenir compte de l'objectif
d'égalité professionnelle entre les
femmes et les hommes et la mixité des
emplois pour les branches qui ne m'ont
pas
opérer de négociation sur ces sujets là
depuis 5 ans moi je souhaite nous
souhaitons avec cet amendement qu'on
tienne compte de la volonté express
des négociateurs de la nid et des
signataires de la nid puisque à la fin
de l'article 4 qui est un des longues
articles de de Lagny il est bien mis
spécifiquement les organisations
signataires je vais reciter ce qui va ça
vient de vous mentionner les
organisations signataires considèrent
qu'il convient d'apprécier les niveaux
de rémunération au regard non seulement
des classifications mais aussi des
métiers repères donc au moment où vous
nous proposez une négociations sur les
classifications
nous vous proposons d'être plus précis
encore une mentionner les métiers
repères alors vous allez me dire comme
le ministre donc je sais pas où est à
cet instant la commission de validation
si j'ose dire par les partenaires
sociaux mais il faut leur poser la
question qui peut le plus peut le moins
surtout quand eux-mêmes ont souhaité
apporter cette précision donc soyons
fidèles à la volonté des négociateurs et
des signataires en y faisant figurer ce
que eux-mêmes ont souhaité voir figurer
alors la question toute la question qui
est posée c'est est-ce que c'est déjà
satisfait est-ce que dire qu'une
négociation sur les classifications
des éléments chacun évidemment est libre
de contacter les uns les autres donc on
aura effectivement un point de retour là
dessus et on espère qu'ils débattront
d'un certain nombre d'éléments qui ont
été rappelés d'ailleurs sur la
qualification du bénéfice exceptionnel
enfin en tout cas les précisions à
l'article l'article 5 et d'autres et
d'autres sujets ça c'est le premier il
faut qu'il le fasse vite puisque toute
façon les délais d'amendement pour la
séance sont fixés à jeudi donc donc
c'est important alors vous avez raison
il y a effectivement deux articles dans
la ni qui traitent de cette question il
y a l'article 3 qui retranscrit dans
l'article premier d'ailleurs qui est le
seul qu'on évoquait à l'instant sur les
classifications et c'est une catégorie
légale qui est inscrite dans la loi et
qui évidemment est indéterminant des
salaires sur sur la branche qui est
considérait et ensuite il y a l'article
4 que vous avez évoqué également qui
mentionne ces métiers repères alors elle
rend pas quand on regarde quand on
regarde les choses dans le détail elle
rend pas obligatoire la révision la
révision
peut-être peut-être qu'il interprète
comme ça en tout cas c'est pas écrit
comme ça mais en fait elle le traite
sous l'angle de l'égalité
professionnelle entre les femmes et les
hommes dans au sein au sein de
l'entreprise donc il y a d'autres
amendements plus tard dans le texte dont
on pourra débattre des battre sur cette
question d'ailleurs moi je propose
éventuellement que vous puissiez
demander aux organisations syndicales si
ça leur convient la rédaction telle
qu'elle existe à l'article qui
retranscrit l'article 3 de la ENI mais
moi ce que je trouve c'est de retirer
cet amendement peut-être de leur poser
la question si ça leur si ça leur
convient il me semble qu'en tout cas la
transposition de l'articles 3 et de
l'article 4 me semble être couverte par
la rédaction actuelle très bien monsieur
le rapporteur
[Musique]
mes collègues députés là voulaient
maintenez très bien alors je mets aux
voix donc l'amendement 211 qui a reçu un
avis défavorable qui est pour
qui est contre
il est rejeté même avis même votre sur
le 1 très bien je vous remercie
amendement suivant monsieur Catteau
merci madame la Présidente cet
amendement vise à diminuer le délai de
négociation liée à la classification
parce qu'effectivement il est prévu au
travers de cet article du coup
négociation aux entreprises qui n'ont
pas négocié depuis 5 ans sauf qu'en 5
ans l'inflation est arrivée le pouvoir
d'achat des Français évidemment abaissé
et donc il est proposé à travers cet
abonnement de baisser à 3 ans
ce délai de négociation et à deux ans
pour les métiers en tension je vous
remercie
très bien monsieur monsieur le
rapporteur
j'entends j'entends ce point donc
effectivement vous la barre appelé votre
amendement vise à faire passer de 5 à 3
ans voir à 2 ans sur les métiers en
tension nous savons qui nous savons
qu'il y en a d'ici à décembre 2023 donc
ça c'était un point de l'article 3 de la
nuit qu'on vient juste débloquer à
l'instant et le délai de 5 ans il est
fixé l'article l2241-7 du Code du
travail qui fixe qui fixe délai maximum
offert à toutes les branches ça a été un
point de des éléments de retour que j'ai
eu sur la négociation qui a été assez
proprement discutée donc j'ai quand même
des 12 sur la capacité des uns des
autres à faire à faire à faire bouger il
y a 60 juste parmi les données du
ministère du travail que nous avons
demandé dans le cadre des travaux il y a
65% des branches qui disposent de gris
de cliffs de classification réviser il y
a plus de 5 ans avec une moyenne de 12
ans je reconnais que ça nécessiterait
que ça aille un peu plus vite il y a
quand même eu des révisions elles ont
été évoquées d'ailleurs par le ministre
pendant son audition qui m'ont quand
même globalement dans le bon sens suite
à l'augmentation du SMIC j'ai pas que
c'est suffisant mais enfin ça a quand
même dans le bon sens il me semble que
c'est un moment qui irait sans doute
enfin assez nettement plus loin que les
éléments d'équilibre qui ont été trouvés
dans l'accord donc mon avis est
défavorable
très bien monsieur le député catho vous
le maintenez très bien je mets aux voix
donc cet amendement qui a reçu un avis
défavorable qui est pour qui contre il
est rejeté amendement suivant qui le
défend c'est celui de Monsieur Petavy
madame oui effectivement c'est un
amendement de mon collègue Sébastien
Petavy qui revient sur le même sujet que
tout à l'heure le groupe est collé
écologiste au travers de cet amendement
réitère sa demande que la révision des
classifications éventuellement négocier
s'effectue également en prenant en
compte la liste des métiers repères je
serai insisté sur le fait que c'est là
où on le voit le plus les
discriminations basées sur le genre et
c'est au travers de des métiers repères
ça a été dit à plusieurs reprises
très bien monsieur le rapporteur votre
avis sur cet amendement oui demande de
retrait pour les mêmes idées pour le
même raison que ce qui a été évoqué par
avec notre collègue Guedj et je propose
qu'on reparle notamment des questions
d'égalité homme-femme un peu plus tard
qui a été femme homme pardon sur les
questions des salaires un peu plus tard
dans la discussion très bien vous le
gardez madame SAS vous le maintenez je
mets où on voit cet amendement qui a
reçu un avis défavorable qui est pour
qui contre il est rejeté amendement
suivant monsieur qui n'ont pas défendu
monsieur Catteau pour le 75 merci madame
la Présidente alors cet amendement vise
à effectivement à trouver une solution
par rapport à ce que la problématique
qu'on rencontre on voit qu'il y a un
grand nombre d'entreprises n'ont pas
négligé en tout cas de branche non pas
négocier du coup dans ce délai de 5 ans
qui avait été proposé par le passé et
donc on vise effectivement un restaurant
à privé les organisations syndicales
qu'elles soient pas tropales ou
syndicales qui n'ont pas qui n'ont pas
du coût négocié dans les 5 ans
à bénéficier finalement de l'argent qui
est proposé par le l'association de
gestion du fond du pari international
afin de d'avoir cette contrainte
financière qui repose sur eux afin de
les inciter à les négocier plus
facilement avec les syndicats et trouver
des solutions par rapport au
classification je remercie très bien
monsieur le rapport
EUR je suis pas totalement sûr que ce
soit une bonne façon d'entamer le
dialogue avec elle voilà donc pour voilà
mais vous pouvez leur en parler mais
j'ai pas trop de doute de leur réponse
donc je suis pas sûr que ce soit
vraiment dans l'idée qu'on a de la
démocratie sociale sur voilà mais bon
voilà donc défavorable très bien vous le
oui monsieur Tavel
et merci
c'est effectivement le principe de
sanctionner les branches qui ne
parviennent pas à négocier et encore
moins à des accords nous y sommes très
attachés il nous semble nous que c'est
sur le levier des exonérations de
cotisations que nous devrions pouvoir
jouer au moins de façon temporaire au
moins à partir d'un certain seuil etc en
revanche la proposition du rassemblement
national et
parfaitement
dangereuse et en plus malhonnête parce
qu'elle revient à accuser les syndicats
de salariés d'être responsables du fait
que leur branche ne négocie pas les
organisations syndicales de salariés ne
sont en rien responsables du fait qu'il
n'y a pas de négociation de branche si
il y a des organisations à sanctionner
parce qu'il n'y a pas assez négociations
cette exclusivement les organisations
patronales